Systems research is 1% inspiration and 99% perspiration. The only way
to convince someone of your ideas is to build a system and evaluate it. Now, how
do you go about evaluating a system such as Spin or ExoKernel? You
can qualitatively argue that you're achieving extensibility
without sacrificing safety. Simply by the way
the system is constructed. But you also have to show that you're not losing
out on performance, due to the extensability
hooks. There's an interesting dilemma when you're
reading research papers. How do you make
sense out of the quantitative results from
a data research paper? When you research
papers, remember that absolute numbers are meaningless.
It is the trends that are meaningful. While doing any performance study of a
new system that you're proposing, you have
to identify what the competition is. Remember
that spin and exokernel were done in the early to mid 90s. For spin
and exokernel, the competition is a monolithic
operating system and a microkernel based operating system.
And the competition at that time for both Spin and exokernel was UNIX as
a monolithic example, and Mach [INAUDIBLE] as
a micro kernel example. And the performance
questions always center around space and time. For example,
how much better timewise, is the extended
kernel, whether it is a spin approach or exokernel approach, compared to
a microkernel-based approach in terms of performance.
And since we know an extended kernel may
have to incur loss of locality and
border crossing overhead and so on compared to
a monolithic kernel, another question that we
may want to ask is, is the extended kernel
at least as good as a monolithic kernel? What is the code size of implementing a
standard operating system, say Unix, as a
monolithic operating system, or a micro kernel based
operating system or an extended kernel operating system.
So that's a space question. And so, we
can have time questions, as well as space questions when we propose a new way of
doing any particular system component. I encourage you
to read the performacne results in the papers.
Key take away that you will see when you read the performance results reported
by both SPIN and exokernel, is that they do much better than Mach, microkernel.
For protected procedure call. That is, when you go from one protection domain to
another, how well are you doing? For
that, both SPIN and exokernel exceed the performance
of Mach. And you also see that both SPIN and exokernel
do as well for dealing with system calls as a monolithic kernel does.